attraction quiz spectacle et spécialités
culinaires
pour sa deuxième édition ce samedi 15
juin la ville demeure pas à miser sur
une fête populaire et familiale
objectif de cette journée rassembler les
habitants
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est de
rassembler voilà toutes les familles de
maurepas sur le thème des traditions du
monde
on a souhaité ouvrir cette manifestation
a pas tous les pays mais en tout cas de
nombreux pays dans le monde pour faire
découvrir voilà les traditions aux
enfants avec des quiz et des jeux
cette année une vingtaine de stands nous
ont emmenés en argentine en france en
écosse ou encore en russie
une fête cosmopolite animé par la ville
une découverte pour les parents et des
jeux pour les enfants c'était bien les
cds un peu facile pour moi et aussi
commander tirer et bavay et tirer dans
chaque sens mais j'arrivais jamais
attiré dans le cerveau et irrite dans la
croix
on était parti sur le continent
sud-américain est bon qu'on a découvert
cette activité l'aller les bolas lancer
des vols avec un élastique entre les
deux et il faut essayer de les enrouler
autour d'une bonne j'espère que ça vous
a plu
des enfants salle tél
prochaine cette journée riche en
découvertes s'est terminée par une
remise de prix présidé par le maire de
la ville
rendez-vous donc l'année prochaine pour
une nouvelle journée en fait un mort pas